dans votre livre c'est ce que disait
valéry vous parlez de trois cas le
premier un bébé secoué est décédé est ce
que c'est ça le plus dur pour vous est
ce que c'est ce type d' enquête
c'est ce dont on a le plus peur quand on
arrive en tout cas moi c'était cool
appréhendiez ce cas là voilà depuis j'en
ai eu
j'en ai eu deux donc le premier a été
plus difficile que le deuxième mais bon
après je sais pas si on s'y habitue je
pense qu'on s'y habitue jamais vraiment
voilà ça fait partie des choses qui sont
qui sont pour nous les plus compliqués à
gérer en terme de deux terribles
détresse des parents et voilà en termes
de décharge émotionnelle c'est assez ça
c'est assez violent
par ailleurs vous expliquer qu'en
lorsque vous raconter l'histoire que
vous prenez sur vous d'aller annoncer
aux parents que c'est la nourrice et
c'est vous qui décidez de le faire alors
que vous auriez pu ne pas être là
porteuses de cette nouvelle là non mais
en même temps ça fait partie du lien
aussi qu'on tisse avec les parents dans
ce genre d'affaires et/ou
et oui je sais la juste distance elle
n'est pas forcément évidente à m et
voilà c'est des personnes qui m'ont
énormément touchés et donc du coup il me
paraissait je pars important d'aller
d'aller moi-même leur ai expliqué parce
que je savais qu'il aurait du mal à le
comprendre parce qu'ils s'y attendait
pas du tout et donc
donc voilà c'est plus facile d'avoir des
gens en face c'est de pouvoir essayer de
trouver les mots justes est ce qu'on les
trouve les mots justes toujours
ce concert est ce que parfois je les ai
paris glg dire je
je pense que je n'aurais pas dû faire
comme ça a certainement là j'ai pas
différente est en tout cas dans ce cas
précis là je pense je pense les avoir
trouvés en tout cas
eux l'ont rendue en remercions
parce que vous aviez fait pour eux quoi
oui oui c'est ça de l'état des lieux
vous faites un travail nécessaire et
même admirable
voilà je vous le dire mais que j'imagine
extrêmement perturbant comment vous
faites pour gérer la presse c'est à dire
votre vie familiale votre vie sociale
votre vie à la maison enfin comment vous
faites un indice par beaucoup c'est un
vrai ça c'est une vraie thérapie pour
moi donc la piscine du jogging et sort
de d'évacuer depuis un certain temps je
médite tous les matins donc ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui contribue
aussi à une certaine voie la stabilité
et je pars régulièrement donc je suis un
peu comme les enfants moi si cette
semaine de travail et j'ai besoin de
déconnecter complètement et de partir
après ses propres à chacun tout le monde
ne fait pas comme moi chacun trouve ses
petites solutions la bricole dans son
élément pour essayer de trouver ce culte
beaucoup entre nous aussi
[Musique]
voilà après le soir quand on rentre ça
reste des dossiers fin sait pas on n'est
pas touché personnellement par les
affaires donc quand on rentre chez toi
il ya une autre vie qui nous attend
derrière et on arrivait justement à
propos de votre vie à la maison
justement vous parlez du rapport que
vous avez avec votre fils et de façon
assez étonnante malgré tout ce que vous
voyez tout ce que vous vivez vous n'êtes
pas forcément très possessive et voulu
laisser quand même sont alors ça c'est
un choix c'est un choix je pas sûr que
ce soit lié à mon métier
pourtant vous pourriez être
particulièrement angoissée parce que
vous savez ce qu'il va vivre ce que
pourraient rencontrer comme comme
horreurs comme voilà je pourrais
maintenant je me dis peut-être naïvement
que comme j'ai une certaine forme d
coûte peut-être que par rapport à
d'autres parents j'aurai la chance de me
rendre compte qu'il y avait un problème
et encore on est souvent à les
cordonniers sont les plus mal chaussés
c'est bien connu mais je je je sais pas
en fait je suis plutôt du style à me
dire que ça sert à rien de stresser pour
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore
arrivé
donc voilà pour l'instant je serais ce
pas qui le jour où ça ou si ça arrive je
pense que j'aurai la situation quant à
elle quand elle arrivera mais vous êtes
bien plus angoissés qu'une autre maman
non merci et bravo parce que c'est de
nous on est très angoissée non mais
parce que j'y suis je
d'avoir la chance d'interviewer olivier
marchal qui a arrêté le métier de
policier qui me disait al'inverse de
vous je n'arrive plus même quand je vais
dans un restaurant par exemple exclu
avec mes filles je scanne à la salle
qu'en bon flic que je suis pour vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas de souci que le mec près
de la porte tout près de la sortie de
secours est à peu près normal et c'est
là mais on ne voyait pas ce que je veux
dire me essais des adolescentes en plus
c'est pas la même chose un petit garçon
est d'accord pour comparaison très
officiel oui la force d'ingurgiter des
affaires comme celle là est ce qu'il ya
pas la faire de trop c'est à dire celle
qui va faire que vous allez dire là
c'est trop je peux plus je vais demander
un changement d'affectation pas encore
je n'y suis pas encore parce que ça fait
trois ans que je suis dans la brigade
est donc j'ai pas encore eu cette
affaire là voilà dieu merci ça peut
arriver mais ça peut arriver et j'ai
j'ai déjà entendu des fonctionnaires de
police dire telle histoire ça a été trop
pour moi parce que parce que dans son
histoire de vie à elle ça pouvait faire
référence à ses enfants ou autres
et voilà et c'est super important je
pense de de bien se connaître pour
savoir le moment où justement c'est trop
et où il faut partir
ouais exactement ça c'est le plus
important et à ce moment là le ce jour
de bascule là vous savez ce que vous
ferez où vous irez comme pas encore non
séparation la chine bradley sans trois
c'est ici maintenant demain je sais pas
ce que c'est comme si toutes les
adolescentes vous ressembler fortement
vida merci beaucoup
merci infiniment ce livre formidable
offerte à lui permettent de connaître
aussi le fonctionnement d'un service
qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on parte en
fantasme un peu et dont on ignorait le
voilà la façon de travailler